number of refugees who have left ukraine
is now more than one and a half million
according to the u.n when you look at
these photos of people and the families
that have traveled for days just to
reach safety food and warmth it's hard
to imagine that millions more could be
displaced as the fighting spreads inside
ukraine let's go back to tony in eastern
poland along the ukrainian border tony
good morning
hey good morning nate i can't say there
is one bit of good news the sun just
peeked out from behind great clouds
first time in two days we've seen that
everyone could use a little bit of
warmth the big question a lot of people
have in the united states and here is
could the united states do something
more to stop the suffering in ukraine
what are they doing now what may be to
come and also physically could we be
involved in direct conflict with russia
i talked to christina cavine the top u.s
diplomat in ukraine about all those
topics take a look
what is your assessment of things as
they stand today
well in ukraine unfortunately the
situation is quite dire
president putin's forces have
attacked in some major cities
or encircled other major cities and
attacked the communities around those
cities so keeve has very heavy fighting
marijual has already been overtaken by
the russians
odessa has troops that are going towards
it
and harkive has been bombed continuously
for days now
are the russians
targeting to your knowledge non-military
installations certainly there have been
many civilian casualties whether they're
targeted or just indiscriminate i don't
know but i can tell you that they're
being hit yesterday anthony blinken said
there's credible evidence of war crimes
committed by the russians
you've seen that evidence i'm not a
lawyer but i would say it is a war crime
and would be a war crime to target
civilians or civilian structures and i
think you can take a look at some of the
news in recent days and draw your own
conclusions is there the possibility as
russia faces ukrainian resistance
supported by the us
that there could be airstrikes here in
poland where the munitions the missiles
the weaponry is landing and going to
ukraine
if there is and russia has declared war
on nato and nato will fight back we've
spoken to members of congress who
described the situation that they've
seen here on the border and also in
ukraine
in terms that evoke world war ii
poland in 1939.
do you think those are fair
if you look at the pictures coming out
of harkev if you look at the pictures
coming out of mariupol where civilians
are trying to flee and russia is
stopping them shooting them on the
street if they try to leave
i think that it certainly uh has some
similarities to those other tragedies
that's saying a lot
how does this end
i don't know how it ends i hope it ends
by the ukrainians being victorious and i
think ultimately it will end by the
ukrainians being victorious hopefully
sooner and hopefully uh with fewer
casualties but anyway it ends the
ukrainians will not let russia occupy it
the ukrainians will fight they're
fighting now and they will continue to
fight and i am convinced that the
ukrainians will ultimately win
i know tony i was wondering that very
same question how does it end if the
bombing continues and people leave their
homes what is left of ukraine what does
putin really have at the end of the day
it's a good question gail one of the
great fears i think everybody watching
this from the outside as well as the
people in ukraine have
is putin may win militarily but if he
tries to then occupy how long could this
fight last a very long time indeed and
that is the worry and i want to add a
detail to why we're seeing so many
people over the border still coming in
over my shoulder and those are new
people those buses leave every 15
minutes or so full to the brim and then
a new crowd arrives the reason they're
here coming across the border one reason
in fact is because the trains that had
been going from levee
into poland are becoming more dangerous
we heard in scott pelley's report last
night on 60 minutes of families being
told to lie down at certain points get
below the window line because of fear of
shooting into the cabins
it gives you an idea as the ambassador
acting ambassador said
all you have to do is watch the news to
make a determination of whether there
are war crimes here draw your own
conclusions guys
exactly right and you report in the last
hour about hangings and rapes we hadn't
heard that before tony thank you very
much